was ist jetzt bei diesem jüngsten
treffen der ermittler passiert wir haben
erfahren dass sie sich tatsächlich in
lissabon zusammen gesetzt haben um mal
den ermittlungsstand zu beleuchten also
die deutschen jetzt hat die federführung
haben die christian bea verdächtigen
maddie mccann entführt und getötet zu
haben wollten ihre kollegen von scotland
yard und der polier der portugiesischen
kriminalpolizei mal auf stand bringen
über inhalt dieses gesprächs ist nicht
bekannt was allerdings bekannt geworden
ist ist eine e mail die danach ein
portugiesischer ermittler an kollegen
geschickt hat und in dieser e-mail geht
er mit den mit den deutschen ermittlern
relativ hart ins gericht ich darf das
mal zitieren
der portugiesische ermittler sagt die
deutschen haben keine beweise nur
spekulationen
als er die deutsche akte lars sei er
schockiert gewesen
zitat ich hätte nie gedacht dass das bka
so schlecht ermitteln würde es gibt
keine ernsthafte unparteiische und
objektive untersuchung sondern nur die
absicht den verdächtigen um jeden preis
im gefängnis zu halten
man muss das jetzt mit ein bisschen
vorsicht genießen
es ist ja als diese geschichte ist läuft
seit 13 jahren es waren zunächst nur die
portugiesen involviert dann irgendwann
haben die engländer übernommen operation
grange hat den fall an sich gerissen
da gab es schon so etwas wie laien also
die portugiesen haben den engländern
vorgeworfen sie würden bevormundet und
man würde ihnen sagen wie man dazu
ermitteln hat und ohnehin seien ja
sowieso die eltern die hauptverdächtigen
operation grange hat die eltern dann
entsprechend entlastet da gab es immer
schon zopf und eifersüchteleien wie viel
diese e-mail eines ermittlers jetzt wert
ist inhaltlich das muss man mal
diskutieren aber ganz offensichtlich ist
der informationsfluss zwischen den drei
beteiligten parteien nicht so wahnsinnig
super bilder zu dem jetzt aber auch
erfahren dass christian beer heute in
einer nicht öffentlichen anhörung vor
gericht steht geht es da um maddie und
diesem fall nein in dem fall heute geht
es nicht um maddie mccann christian b
wurde aus der jva kiel heute mittag nach
braunschweig gefahren weil es vor dem
landgericht dort eine anhörung gibt
da geht es um folgendes er ist ja vom
landgericht niebel vor geraumer zeit zu
einem jahr und neun monaten haft wegen
drogenhandels verurteilt worden diese
art strafe hat er jetzt mehr als zwei
dritteln abgesessen das heißt er hat das
recht wie jeder strafgefangene dass der
rest der strafe zur bewährung ausgesetzt
und aus dem knast entlassen wird
das ist im falle christian b eine sehr
theoretische überlegung weil wir wissen
ja dass du noch einiges anhängig ist dh
es ist nicht zu erwarten dass er da
heute dass ich dort viel tut
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren